foreign
everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is SCP 3041
object class safe
special containment procedures
scp-3041 is to be kept in a secure
Locker on site researchers are not to
hold scp-3041 or allow it to come into
contact with their bare skin
as a 522 2015 all access to scp-3041 is
prohibited pending further review
furthermore until this review is
complete the information below should be
regarded as outdated and possibly
inaccurate
description
scp-3041 is a 12 centimeter iron knife
of unidentified origin with a hilt
wrapped in braided leather radiometric
dating shows inconclusive results for
the age of the blade but indicates the
hilt was added within the past two
centuries the knife's surface is rust
colored and smells of spoiled meat
despite extensive analysis a source for
this odor has yet to be determined
scp-3041 exhibits its anomalous property
only once it has been held by a Sapient
subject for a certain period of time the
length of time required to trigger
scp-3041's effect varies widely the
underlying mechanism remains unknown
once scp-3041 has activated subjects
will eventually experience a dream
wherein they use scp-3041 to attack one
or more persons removing and consuming
their hearts this dream is set wherever
the subject initially held scp-3041 and
typically involves victims one would
expect to find in this setting in all
cases subjects do not recognize their
victims no victim is known to correlate
with an actual person alive or dead
subjects will often continue to have
reoccurrences of this dream with little
variation though amnestics reduce or
even eliminate these occurrences most
subjects continue to show signs of
emotional distress guilt and
psychological trauma associated with
post-traumatic stress syndrome
scp-3041's effect can be triggered
multiple times producing new dreams in
each case
scp-3041 was found among the personal
effects of Daniel Crenshaw an elderly
recluse and collector of historical
antiques who committed on O2 15 1987.
scp-3041's anomalous nature was
discovered when in reviewing the
contents of Mr crenshall's collection a
researcher began experiencing dreams
similar to those described in Mr
crunchel no
addendum 3041 1. attachments
access scp-3041 tests Series 5 log
notably this was the last series of
tests performed with scp-3041
subject d-85373
summary
d-85373 was placed in a room alone with
scp-3041 and asked to hold it for 10
minutes
result sleep study revealed no unusual
sleeping patterns
d-85373 reported no unusual dreams
researcher note nothing unexpected
subject d-85373
summary
d-85373 was placed in a room alone with
scp-3041 and asked to hold it for 10
minutes
result sleep study revealed acute night
terrors
d-85373 described a nightmare in which
she used scp-3041 to ritualistically
mutilate another occupant in the room
over the course of 30 minutes finally
devouring his heart although d-85373
described the victim as someone wearing
a d-class uniform the victim's
description fit no d-class Personnel on
site furthermore no d-class Personnel on
site were reported as absent or missing
researcher note still unable to
determine what triggers scp-3041's
effect possibly repetition of exposure
subject d-85373
summary
d-85373 was placed in a room alone with
scp-3041 and asked to hold it for 10
minutes
result sleep study revealed acute night
terms
d-85373 described A New Nightmare in
which she had used scp-3041 to attack
and mutilate a researcher who entered
the room at the end of the test no
researcher on site fit
d-85373's description
furthermore no researcher on site was
reported as absent or missing
researchers note we ought to include
additional d-class Personnel in the room
during testing to see if they are
incorporated into the subject's
nightmares
subject d-85373
summary
d-85373 was placed in a room alone with
scp-3041 and asked to hold it for 10
minutes
result sleep study revealed a cute night
terrors
d-85373 now described a nightmare
wherein she attacked and devoured the
hearts of two d-class Personnel again
the description of the victims fit no
on-site d-class personnel and no d-class
Personnel were reported absent or
missing
researchers note despite having left
explicit instructions to include
additional d-class Personnel in the room
the test was carried out with only
d85373 I will oversee the next test
personally
also staff has started to complain of a
peculiar smell in the lab
linked to scp-3041
subject d-85373
summary
d-85373 was placed in a room alone with
scp-3041 and asked to hold it for 10
minutes
result several hours into the test
d-85373 doubled over and complained of
extreme stomach pain shortly thereafter
she passed out after being rushed to the
infirmary it was determined that her
stomach had ruptured
she died shortly thereafter from septic
shock
an autopsy gave no indication as to the
cause despite pronounced swelling her
stomach was empty
researchers note
after analysis of notes I took during
this test I found that I had made nine
separate attempts to have two d-class
Personnel enter the room I have no
recollection of doing this in fact
outside of d85373 there are and it never
have been any d-class Personnel assigned
to scp-3041
on top of all this the smell throughout
the lab has become unbearable
I've ordered the immediate cessation of
all tests with scp-3041 pending review
by the site director
access
scp-3041 tests admin memo lock
2. researchers assigned to scp-3041
subject immediate action cease all
testing
after a careful review of laboratory
procedures test footage and personal
records associated with scp-3041 the
following inexplicable discrepancies
have been noted
despite regulations requiring each SCP
have both a lead researcher and an
assistant lead researcher it appears
only a lead researcher was assigned to
scp-3041
the reason behind this oversight is
currently under review
critical site-wide shortages of d-class
personnel have been reported since
testing with scp-3041 began these
shortages have yet to be explained while
no d-class Personnel appear to be absent
or missing only a fraction of the
expected number of d-class personnel are
present
despite each test with scp-3041 reported
as lasting only 10 minutes video footage
for each test ranges from 10 minutes to
4 hours
furthermore when viewed this footage
exhibits what is believed to be a
Cognito Hazard effect only portions of
the video can be perceived by viewers
despite several thorough examinations
the labs used for testing scp-3041
continue to smell of rotting meat this
effect remains unexplained and is likely
very anomalous
for these reasons all testing with
scp-3041 is to be suspended until
further notice
scp-3041 is to be secured in an on-site
safe box immediately all Labs used to
test scp-3041 are to undergo a Class 6
decontamination procedure and all
Personnel involved in testing are to be
examined for potential infection with
anti-memetic agents
access scp-3041 files note log
the following note was found at Mr
crenshaw's desk shortly after his Bonnie
was discovered
and it still won't stop
in it my arm is wet with blood the
nation hand glittering like a brilliant
shining Ruby
my heart beats like a drum before me
I see the faces of strangers contorted
in agony screaming from Mercy
a woman a man
children three girls and a little baby
boy
how do not know them
[Applause]
but the open
cut them open and then I eat their
hearts
I know it's just a nightmare but
I feel so real so vivid
and there are times when I swear I can
taste raw meat on the back of my tongue
where I can feel it sliding down my
throat into my belly
I've lived a long only life
I've never known friends or family so
why do I live in a house with so many
rooms when is each room fill me with
guilt and Dread
why can't I bring myself to go down to
my basement
why does it smell like robbing flesh
and wind away on a crib
my nightmare took place under the house
I've never gone down to look
afraid
if you're reading this then you'll have
to look for me maybe you'll find nothing
I pray you'll find nothing
neither I'm crazy or I'm the devil
does God love me be crazy
despite a thorough investigation of Mr
crenshaw's basement researchers reported
that the only thing of note was the
overpowering odor of rancid meat
okay I think that about does it for
today
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Big sip
tomothy
zargaron
the Morrigan
James Saba
oh crap guy
heroin sick
Cassie 11.
fire of prime
ND versus the world
Spencer are doing
rubbish bin 69.
Dr Wolf 13.
copster
worthy fire
zazapan
Lemke
signor
a la trayon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
and Lyndon B Johnson
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you